alors Frédéric gr on vous reçoit ce soir
parce que vous avez reçu il y a quelques
semaines le titre de portraitiste de
France 2013 avec la mention excellence
donc c'est un titre très très très
honorable et notamment dans les ivelines
et dans le dans le départ même dans
l'île-de-fance puisque peu de de
photographes ont ce titre alors pourquoi
c'est un concours qu'est-ce qui vous a
amené qu'est-ce qui vous a motivé pour
participer à ce concours ben déjà mon
passé de sportif j'aime la compétition
donc j'aime bien mesurer aux autres euh
après aussi ça permet de juger un peu
son travail par par ses pères en fait
euh et bien évidemment aussi le côté euh
au niveau de la communication ben c'est
c'est intéressant par rapport au c'est
un plus hein de pouvoir afficher ce
titre aussi par rapport au aux autres
photographes exctement ça crée un peu la
la différence sur le département aussi
VO aussi le département et même la
région puisque'en fait en Île-de-France
jamais personne n'a eu cette mention en
fait voilà d'accord et alors comment se
déroule ce concours qu'est-ce que vous
avez dû présenter alors en fait on doit
présenter 12 images euh h images en
portrait et quatre images en mariage
alors on voit quelquesunes des photos
donc il y avait des des thématiques
imposé libre comment ça s'est passé ou
en fait il y a une partie qui est
imposée on devait absolument proposer
une image en grossesse une image
d'enfant une image de d'une femme
et une im AG de famille h euh et ensuite
il y avait quatre images de mariage
imposé et les quatre autres images
étaient libre d'accord donc l'idée de
l'imposer et du libre c'est que pour
pour qu'il y ait des critères bien
précis sur sur l'imposé et puis surtout
vous m'aviez vous m'aviez indiqué que
sinon d'autres trichaient un peu en
faisant appel qu'il a des modèles alors
forcément voilà c'està-dire que là en
fait ça permet de montrer réellement le
travail du photographe dans dans son
studio avec ses vrais clients sans faire
appel à des des des des personnes
extérieures qui peuvent venir poser que
pour le concours là voilà quelqu'un qui
quand on demande de faire une photo de
grossesse on peut pas faire appel à un
modèle quoi voà est-ce qu'on peut juste
revoir la la dernière photo celle celle
du bébé est-ce que vous trichez pour ces
photos vous les retoucher ou pas parce
que pour réaliser ce cliché là c'est
beaucoup de patience ou ouais alors
c'est c'est très dur à faire je vais
être honnête avec vous euh depuis que je
tente cette photo il y a que trois
clients qui l'ont eu tous ilavent h mais
en fait c'est super dur à faire faut
être très patient il faut que bébé dorme
très profondément et le rendu est super
c'est excellent voilà et cette image a
été primée en Italie en fait oui parce
qu' alors du coup ça nous amène d'où ce
titre aussi de de renom international
c'est vous avez deux Award de bronze
pour un concours aussi en Italie voilà
maintenant vous attaquer l'international
alors c'est c'était quoi ce concours
aussi ben en fait c'est un concours qui
est organisé à Orvieto c'est le plus
grand concours photo professionnel en
Italie et donc en fait mon papa photo
Gérard cimetière il a participé et j'ai
vu son mur Facebook en fait qu'il y
participait et j'ai envoyé les images et
donné envie de exactement et et j'ai eu
envie d'essayer et puis voilà et puis
après j'ai eu ben la chance d'avoir deux
images primées alors quel critère vous
savez un petit peu les critères des
juris sur quoi il se basent parce que la
photo ça reste de l'art donc c'est
subjectif à priori mais est-ce qu'il y a
aussi des des de véritables critères
plus formels alors pour le titre de
portetire de France oui il y a des
critères qui sont ben les critères tels
que la lumière la composition l'effet
waou enfin voilà ces choses-là qu'est-ce
que c'est l'ffet ben en fait ben
exactement comme wifried vient de faire
quand il a vu la photo il a dit est-ce
qu'on peut la revoir ben en fait c'est
ça les fa wou c'est une image qui vous
interpelle euh et vous savez pas
pourquoi c'est parce que vous la trouvez
jolie voilà par contre en Italie là
honnêtement je connais pas du tout les
les critères en fait ben voilà il y a il
y a il y a des catégories en italien
c'est une est-ce qu'on peut aller
chercher ça en régie est-ce qu'on peut
me le dire dans l'or donc voilà après il
y a des catégories par contre d'accord
moi je je participe à la catégorie
portrait mais il y a il y a le paysage
le mariage l'industriel et cetera voilà
donc les images quand même sont
sectorisées par catégorie et une séance
type si vous pouvez rapidement nous dire
c'est comment ça se passe d'un premier
l'accueil des clients au studio puis
déjà ils ont reçu par mail une plaquette
qui leur dit un petit peu comment ça va
se dérouler euh on commence toujours par
faire des photos avec les enfants si
c'est des enfants un petit peu rigolotes
quoi pour les détendre un petit peu
parce que c'est pas facile de poser
quand on n pas l'habitude et puis euh et
puis voilà ben on fait euh vous faites
beaucoup de clichés avant d'en
sélectionner un qui sera potiellement le
bon en fait on fait oui on fait pas mal
de le numérique a permis ça c'est
justement de de de faire euh euh
plusieurs photos en fait euh dans
différentes attitudes et euh et pour
voir justement montrer ensuite aux
parents euh
plusieurs photos et pas qu'une euh parce
qu'ils aiment bien aussi avoir un petit
peu différentes expressions de leurs
enfantsû alors votre activité marche
bien vous le dites he vous avez pas peur
de le dire et votre esprit de
compétiteur toujours en action vous
reprenez là aujourd'hui enfin vous
décidez en tout cas de mener une
nouvelle activité c'est les photos en
extérieur alors c'est très différent les
photos en extérieur ah ouais ça n'a rien
à voirou alors là mais alors vraiment
rien à voir par rapport au studio parce
qu'en fait on ne on ne gère pas la
lumière bah si d'un coup il y a il y a
plus de soleil il y a plus de et cetera
et cetera alors qu'un studio c'est nous
le patron entre guillemets on fait ce
qu'on veut euh il y a une chose qu'on
qu'on maîtrise pas non plus si on va
dans un parc s'il y a des des gens qui
passent ben donc c'est beaucoup plus de
travail de retouche pour enlever tout
ces petites choses qu'on a pas envie de
voir sur les images de ces enfants et
euh et donc c'est tout nouveau parce
qu'en fait j'ai fait un tableau dans mon
studio avec ma petite fille et tous les
clients depuis 2 ans que ce tableau est
dans le studio me disent on aimerait ça
on aimerait ça donc c'est une vraie
demande en fait
c'est vraiment eux qui m'ont poussé à
mettre ça j'ai hésité longtemps parce
que je vous dis c'est vraiment euh euh
totalement différent du studio comme
vous le voyez en ce moment il pleut les
deux journées c'est le 15 et 16 juin
s'il pleut il faut tout annuler quoi
donc donc voilà il faut pas trop de
soleil non plus parce que trop de soleil
c'est pas bon contrairement à ce que
tous les gens pensent on aimerait bien
en avoir un peu quand même hein oui mais
alors juste voyez le top c'est un petit
peu de soleil avec quelques nuages pour
filtrer la lumière pasêre trop difficile
c'est déjà pas facile justement d'avoir
le soleil alors s'il y en a juste même
un peu ça va êre alors donc on rappelle
ces deux journées probables on l'espère
donc fonction du temps ce sera donc le
15 et le 16 juin euh pour toutes les
infos donc on vous contacte via votre
site internet ou le portable qui s'est
qui s'est affiché c'est ça et c'est un
samedi et un dimanche je précise pour
justement donner l'opportunité aux gens
qui travaillent le samedi
exceptionnellement de j'ai décidé de
travailler le dimanche dimanche voilà
très bien merci à